[Music]
sometimes you just want to play a new
game but you don't have the cash to
scratch that itch well fear not
PlayStation have your back with over 50
free to play again
on ps4 ps3 and Vita as well over the
next few days we'll break down a handful
of games for each of the consoles we
think that you should try some of which
have been out for years and some of only
just come out this month if this proved
to be any help please give it a like and
maybe share this with a friend or two
thank you
depending on where you are in the world
means you may not have access to same
free game but I've tried my best to make
these globally available and also keep
in mind that most of these games require
PS Plus ok so let's do this this episode
is dedicated to the ps4 let's start off
with let it die this is one of the most
charismatic and bombastic games on the
list it's clear to see this is based on
the mechanics of Dark Souls and the
title should also prepare you to die a
lot following a catastrophic event a
huge Tower has appeared in Tokyo and
your task to get to the top of it of
course the fighting is a whole lot of
fun but misses the skill-based timing of
Dark Souls but the weapon crafting makes
up for that and occasionally you'll feel
like you're playing Dead Rising this is
at the top of the list for a reason and
it's definitely worth your time it's
probably the greatest game ever made
yeah
this game let it die kill strand is next
on the list and is free to all PS Plus
members originally released in 2016 the
key additions and patches make this one
worth your time this is an online PvP
that player versus player that picks
three teams against one another what's
pretty cool about this one is the
ability to change the team sizes by
spreading the strain so to speak and
turning humans into mutants daily
missions XE leveling and even perks it's
all here that's enough killing people
for a while let's look at the boss and
football or soccer if you prefer as 2017
trial edition is essentially an expanded
demo of the full game designed to get
FIFA fans to switch teams PES is
brilliant and doesn't require me to talk
about the mechanic but keep in mind the
missing elements in this free-to-play
title quick online match is missing
champions league is not here become a
legend have been cooked and the secret
master league is a mix if you can get
past those flaws just enjoy this
football sin that really rivals FIFA in
almost every way do you have the SBR or
should I say do you have something to
play on your psvr as early adopters to a
new piece of hardware it can sometimes
be difficult to find enough content
that's where the zoom arcade comes in I
think I'm pronouncing that right yes I
know the title is terrible but this has
a lot of potential this is an arcade
with multiple mini games to try out you
can even track how many calories you've
lost if that's something you're into
virzoom are kids use these tokens and
credit systems to push you into buying
additional turn just like the arcades of
the 1980s and 90s ride a unicorn drive a
tank
there's something for everyone
[Music]
if you're a fan of telltale games and
their wondrous choose your own adventure
stories then you can pick up Episode one
of minecraft story mode in this title
you explore the blocky world of
Minecraft playing as young builder Jesse
and all his friends on their way to a
building competition but you say at that
point things do not go to plan it's that
something interesting to you you can
grab it now on PSN also telltale
regularly giveaway the first episode in
again we've had Walking Dead Season 1 &
2 tales from the borderlands and game of
throne so exactly worth checking back if
you fancy trying some azure titles too
if you fancy punching people in the face
then give Dead or Alive 5 last round a
try if you've ever played street fighter
ii or mortal kombat you pretty much know
what to expect here like list says this
is a cut-down version of the full game
with limited fighters to choose from and
the story mode is locked do a 5 is
trying to get you to purchase characters
after you inevitably get freezin up by
most of them never winter is your
massively multiplayer online
role-playing games or munawwara shock
offering a similar play and experience
to World of Warcraft this one has
hundreds upon hundreds of hours of
gameplay as you explore your
surroundings and battle multiple enemies
space in a Dungeons & Dragons X well
expect regular and heavy updates and
patches for this one as it attempts to
make you forget about your schoolwork
your housework your job or even going
outside
[Music]
another gear which could take over your
life is Star Trek Online
it's another mm or which came out last
year and follows the PC version this is
a similar experience to Neverwinter but
with the sci-fi setting instead but the
key difference is the space combat where
you captain a Starfleet ship around the
galaxy the additional lighting effects
make this really engaging but I'm a Star
Wars man so I'm gonna leave it in the
sea and on the ground
we are the shield of the Federation in
the final frontier
we work for a better tomorrow we are
Starfleet how about a rhythm game
Hatsune Miku I offer pronounce that
right Project Diva future tone again
this is more like a demo than a full
game and you will only have the chance
to try out two tracks your job is to
perfectly time the boss impresses with
the on-screen prompts to complete Miku's
performance this is making me slightly
uncomfortable so let's move on let's
finish with a strategy title in the
shape of battle islands commanders this
is all about the art of war as you take
part in world war ii battle from the
safety of your couch coordinate attack
and plunge offensive maneuvers in real
time build your army defeat your
opponent this kind of feels like command
& Conquer which is a good thing
so that's ten free to play video games
on your ps4 which you can play right now
in April we're also getting drawn to
death which is going to be massive in
the meantime hopefully you found
something on this list that you can play
do as a favor and give us a like and
maybe even subscribe I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I'll see you next
time
[Music]